[Applause]
welcome to drew's news summertime
edition
[Applause]
and on today's special digital edition
we're talking the latest trends
and we're starting with weddings
oh roswell no i can't wait to get your
take on this
vogue interviewed seven pro wedding
planners to find out how people are
tying the knot
these days i mean it is a new world and
people are being extremely inventive um
they say that wedding parties you can
think small
or even obsolete many people are going
for more intimate affairs
i'd see a frown on your face you're not
liking this you're on a ticker tape
parade
yeah i feel ya uh-huh next you can think
of
hosting those those nuptials on zoom
um people are live streaming to include
friends and family who can't travel
i want one i don't think i get this is
hard for me
i don't i i yeah if anyone objects
please unmute your zoom
and let it be heard now exactly um
i you i don't know this is i i this is
odd to me
um i do think that there is a
green element to maybe a lack of
travel but i i can't i can't get behind
this one
it's a wedding and you know i mean i'm
in the middle of planning a wedding
right now i've never done it before it
is the most stressful thing
because you know i want to get it right
the one time i'm going to do it
and this pandemic during during that
everyone sort of postponed their wedding
so getting a venue now is impossible
so reinventing it the rethinking it is
the only way it's the only option now
for anybody who's doing it
can you help me there's i i don't know i
i don't think i can get behind this one
okay i i know i'm not going to minimize
it i i want to go are you going to zoom
your wedding now good i don't i i don't
frown upon it because if anyone's doing
it for
lack of funds or lack of resources or
wanting to include more people or just
embracing the new technology
then that's great um i have a little
zoom fatigue so i don't think i'm the
best person to advocate for this story
you know i will say
i did get engaged on zoom i don't know
if you remember i told you the story
i do because our people our friends and
family were spread out all over the
world and i thought it would be really
almost cold but it was it actually was
still intimate it was
the engagement now that being said isn't
that enough haven't i done enough
haven't i suffered enough can't i get
married in like a big
thing with it i want like yeah what's
the ideal wedding well you know okay
it's going to be
pretty gay
[Laughter]
all right well this next story is sure
to raise some eyebrows
we've all heard about that bump in
plastic surgery called the zoom boom
it's what happens after we've all spent
like all year
looking at ourselves in a little box on
zoom and seeing our faces and being like
well refinery29 reports before you go
under the needle
why not lift those brows with brow talks
you heard of botox i have well it's not
that
instead brow artists like joey healy say
you can brow talks at home
simply with your tweezers here's the
method start by locating your brow bone
and make sure
the brow is firmly on the bone and not
below it
then just take out your tweezers and
selectively tweeze to reveal the brow
bone
and create a little arch shape and it's
going to see what's happening there just
doing that a little bit
it's going to give you that lift that
you need without having by the way
that zit is due to plucking really i
said don't pluck the hairs in the wrong
direction what did i do i plugged it in
the wrong direction i'm getting a third
eye
is that a thing plucking in the wrong
door what do you mean wrong direction
your eyebrows in the direction that they
grow
if you if they're growing this way you
pluck this way you never want to
do it that way because it goes and it
takes the inside of the follicle and it
rips it out of its root and can create
an irritation therefore a zit see as a
natural beauty these are things i just
don't have to worry about
check out the way your hair is growing
and pluck that direction good to
thank you drew for that i didn't know
that i'd try yeah all right well
everyone get your tweezers out i like
this suggestion
um because everybody can buy a pair of
tweezers and do this oh yeah
so when it's something a little more
elaborate you know
it's a it's not as doable this is like i
can't i
want to try it i'm going home and trying
it tonight you know where by the way tip
to get a pair of tweezers
99 cent store really get your tweezers
and your clippers and all that stuff
there
i love the 99 cent store i go little
bananas in there
um thank you so much for always being
here um with me rossi and thank you to
everyone at home we hope we get to see
you real soon
[Music]
you